Any self-respecting Pixar fan
could tell you that the
animation company's movies
are filled with references
and Easter eggs of its back catalog.
But producer Mark Nielsen has
admitted that there's nods
to every single Pixar
movie in "Toy Story 4."
We're gonna be exploring them in 3, 2, 1.
As usual, we will be
issuing a spoiler alert
because we're about to be revealing
some details from the film.
The movie opens with a
flashback to nine years ago,
explaining the absence of
Bo Peep from "Toy Story 3."
She was last spotted
seen with Woody, Buzz,
Jessie, and Wheezy in "Toy Story 2,"
but fans complained that it wasn't clear
whether she'd been broken or was donated.
Outside, the license plate
on the car is RMR F97.
License plates have been used in "Cars"
and "Toy Story 2" to mean
a whole range of things.
This one refers to when "Toy Story 2"
was accidentally deleted
from Pixar's edit system.
RMR F97 was the command
on the computer that deleted the film,
which had to be restored
using a backup file.
Bo Peep assists Woody in
rescuing RC from a storm drain.
A card is passed through the
group to use as a launchpad.
On this card is a crude
drawing of Rainbow Unicorn
from "Inside Out."
Joy: I loved you in
"Fairy Dream Adventure Part Seven."
OK, bye.
Woody: Are a toy!
You belong to Bonnie!
Shardlow: Take a closer look at the boxes
at the back of the classroom
when Bonnie creates Forky.
One of them belongs to
Anton, a possible reference
to food critic Anton Ego in "Ratatouille."
Bonnie's room has some similarities
to the wallpaper in Andy's
room in "Toy Story."
And later in the film, we see a bedspread
full of Pizza Planet-style rockets
that are the same as
in the original movie.
The van that the family
goes on vacation in
is a Tri-County RV.
This links to references
to Tri-County International
Airport in "Toy Story 2"
and Tri-County Landfill in "Toy Story 3."
One of the vacation spots
is a home that looks eerily similar
to the "Incredibles" house.
Woody and Forky come across
Second Chance Antiques.
The store sign tells us
that it was established in
1986, the same year as Pixar.
Also, the building address is 1200.
Now, Pixar is based
at 1200 Park Avenue,
Emeryville, California.
Outside the antique store
is a Ship It removals van.
This same company van crops
up in "Toy Story of Terror."
Inside the store is where we get lots
of movie references packed in.
There's a vintage record from
Chalupa Records, from "Coco."
There's a green diver's mask
and tiki heads from the
fish tank in "Finding Nemo."
Bo Peep slides past a plate
that has an ornate-looking
symbol from "Brave" in it.
This plate can be seen in several shots.
A yellow plane hanging near the window
resembles Sunwing from "Planes."
There are also awards cases
from Gusteau's office in "Ratatouille"
and furniture from "The Incredibles."
Take a closer look at the key
that the antique-store
staff member is holding.
It looks very much like Sora's Keyblade
from "Kingdom Hearts."
Fans have speculated that this is a nod
to the upcoming Square Enix
title "Kingdom Hearts III."
The antagonists from the antique store
are a group of vintage toys.
The ventriloquist dummy Vincent
bears a resemblance to Slappy
the Dummy from "Goosebumps,"
and Gabby Gabby has the
same yellow bows and dress
as Chatty Cathy from the 1960s.
Here's where "The Shining" comes in.
From carpets to
garbage-truck license plates,
Stanley Kubrick's film
has made an appearance
in many "Toy Story" movies.
A record is put on playing
"Midnight, the Stars and You,"
as performed by Ray
Noble and his orchestra.
This is the same song as played
at the end of "The Shining,"
as the camera pans out from a photograph
showing Jack smiling at
the Overlook Hotel ball.
Fans have also suggested that
the old lady's home address
when attacked by Ducky and Bunny is 237.
So keep an eye out for that.
Combat Carl is back!
We see a Combat Carl doll
being blown up by Sid in
the first "Toy Story."
This version, though, is
a Carl Weathers lookalike
from "Toy Story of Terror."
Rumor has it that John Lasseter
wanted to use a G.I. Joe
doll in the original movie,
but Hasbro was upset that
the doll would be blown up,
so they agreed to make up a brand instead.
Buzz flies into a
purple-and-yellow spiderlike ride
that has the same color palette as Zurg,
his enemy in "Toy Story 2."
There's a spinning ride
next to the Ferris wheel
with a purple-and-yellow
umbrella structure.
This looks exactly like the
sundrop flower from "Tangled."
A stall is called Jet Stream,
echoing the character
alias Strut Jetstream.
Strut Jetstream: Man,
what's going on here!
Is everybody getting to fly today?
Shardlow: It's in this fairground
that Bo Peep loses her arm.
Throughout Disney-owned
franchises, characters lose an arm
in a nod to Luke
Skywalker's amputation scene
at the end of "The Empire Strikes Back."
Bo's sheep bring her a bottle cap
and a safety pin while out foraging.
The cap they give her
is from the same
grape-soda bottle in "Up."
Later in the film,
Buzz gets trapped in a
ring-toss-style game.
Other prizes include
the guitars from "Coco,"
rockets featuring the Pixar ball,
and a red-and-yellow stuffed toy flame,
resembling Anger in "Inside Out."
Think Duke Caboom looks a bit familiar?
He actually cropped up in "Incredibles 2,"
lying in the corner of Jack-Jack's crib.
Bo and Woody approach the secret entrance
for a club in the antique store.
Above this, we see a
decoration for Catmull's Brews,
after Ed Catmull, the
long-standing studio exec
who's stepping down after "Toy Story 4."
Bo presses a 25-cents button
on the slot machine to enter the club.
The number 25 pops up a
few times in the film.
This could be a nod to the "Toy
Story 3" maker Lee Unkrich,
who's stepping down at Pixar
after 25 years in 2019.
Inside the club, we meet Tin Toy
from the 1988 Pixar short "Tin Toy,"
and the eagle from "Toy Story Toons."
So think Mr. Potato Head sounds familiar?
Don Rickles' voice is
actually in the movie
despite the fact that
the actor died in 2017.
He had signed on to the
movie before his death,
and his vocal likeness was
compiled through various shorts,
games, and theme-park voiceovers.
And yes, we found A113.
It's a door number from the
California Institute of Arts,
and it's a number that crops up
in nearly every single Pixar movie.
Also, did you spot Dinoco Gas?
The RV stops there.
It's the same chain of gas stations
that Woody and Buzz get stranded at
in the original "Toy Story."
Look closer at the poster for the movie,
and you'll see a reference to "Up."
A painting hangs on the
wall behind the gang
of dogs playing poker,
the same dogs that Russell sailed past
holding a bunch of balloons.
Think you spotted anything that we missed?
Comment below.